joining us on the second day of
provider the symposium on spatial by
terrific
global scale really fun afternoon and
evening yesterday and welcome you to the
second day today we're in the morning
we'll be focusing on remote sensing and
modeling by the risky data jointly with
remotely sensed data or actually just
think about it remote derived for remote
sensing products that could be extremely
valuable for biodiversity modeling and
cover this area I'm really pleased to
have some of the real experts figure
that's actually in this country present
here today first one of them is woody
Turner is helping set up the by the
recipient program within NASA and this
evening it really instrumental in
supporting research connecting
biodiversity science with remote sensing
data and we'll be talking about
similarly the pieces for global
biodiversity monitoring and assessment
framework for security thanks everybody
right to be here Thank You Walter for
setting this fascinating symposium up
I've really enjoyed yesterday learned a
lot it's a great group of folks and
thank you all for coming back and for
those who are for the first time welcome
so what I'm trying to talk about is I'm
a I'm a program manager at NASA I fund
the use of satellite remote sensing to
understand biodiversity and to try to do
modeling a biodiversity for applications
in a program called ecological
forecasting and so I'm going to talk
about remote sensing and how I think
it's relevant or it feeds into
understanding biodiversity at the global
scale which is the subject of the
symposium which have to admit I'm still
a little uncertain about how we're
really going to do biodiversity globally
I have my doubts on dark days I
sometimes think it's it's just too big
of a stretch but yesterday afternoon was
really great in terms of sort of pumping
me up and really reinforcing the fact
that you know what I've been working on
what a number of you guys have been
working on for some time really is going
to lead us to a capacity to understand
what's happening to biodiversity
globally the same way as we approach
climate globally and then to also do
something about in terms of better
better conservation so what I'd like to
talk about today from that perspective
is what the pieces would be if we were
to set up a global biodiversity
monitoring and assessment framework what
those pieces are and I hope I'm going to
be fairly optimistic and saying I think
most of the pieces are already here that
technically this is doable the
challenges are mostly social and
cultural and but regardless it's really
time for us to get started so quick
outline just talked about the need I
don't think have to spend too much time
on that in this group I am going to
spend some time talking about remote
sensing and how it relates to to
biodiversity which is a big leap for a
lot of people again based on the talks
yesterday probably not such a big leap
for for most of us but for a number of
folks it's sort of the challenge of wolf
I can't see the critters in the pixel
how good could this stuff really be this
remote sensing really be to my to
address my problem to get a research
problem or an applications issue so get
to that then look at some plans that
have been out in the literature in terms
of bringing this together in a global
framework old and new then look at the
pieces of that framework talk about
parallels to climate model monitoring
and assessment which i think you know
they've been through this there's some
ways 20 years out in front of the
biodiversity community in terms of
bringing the tools together to do
monitoring at a global scale it says I
think we can learn a lot we have
different challenges than the climate
community does all bid I think it's
harder to do it for biodiversity but I
still think we can learn some important
lessons from them talk about some issues
and challenges and then hopefully leave
you thinking wow that you know we really
can do this so there was a there was a
another symposium a few weeks ago at the
Smithsonian we're
they were making the case that we're now
in the geological age known as the
Anthropocene which is a birth driven
planet essentially and folks today
they're talking about climate change
talking about biodiversity loss there
were climatologist they were ecologists
there are historians there were artists
of course there was also a geologist
there who sort of stood back and said
well you know if you think about 4.5
billion years of Earth history we're not
really all that big of a deal as much as
we think we are and in terms of leaving
you know a rock record of our impact the
earth is going to be pretty agnostic as
to whether we were here or not Frank and
so she's sort of left the air you can
feel sort of the air coming out of the
room you know surprised they didn't you
know Lynch or something but is she sort
of put us in that perspective and I
think though we all sort of came away
from that feeling that well if we're not
a geological species and we could debate
that and we want we're at least a
globally biologically impactful species
in terms of the impact we're having on
living systems I think it's truly truly
global and just to point out that
whether you look at biodiversity and how
it's changing from a species area of
relationship and sort of estimate from
that which is a common tool that's used
to estimate biodiversity loss and
anticipated by ID law biodiversity loss
or if you get down as the Living Planet
Index has done and actually look at
numbers of things we know things we
count in this case vertebrates both are
pointing in the same direction
biodiversity is declining and is likely
to continue doing so so I think we
clearly have a global challenge this is
a global problem glow will challenge and
therefore it demands not only local and
regional responses but a global response
and that's where I think satellite data
has something to offer in that you know
another blue marble image for you guys
to enjoy a little bit later than John's
from yesterday that just to say that
when when NASA thinks about earth
science when we do or science we
approach earth as a planet so like we do
Mars or Jupiter or another body outside
the solar
in terms of the whole and trying to
understand how the parts of that hole
interact the atmosphere is the oceans
the lands solid earth and the biota that
reside on it and so that that's that's
that sort of top-down approach and
frankly you could argue that the earth
science program at NASA has really been
a child of the Anthropocene this image
other images that put earth and sort of
the broader context and made us appear
like a relatively small made the planet
seemed like a relatively small object in
a pretty dark and large universe and
thus a relatively fragile object drive
the environmental movement that that
John spoke so eloquently about yesterday
and our funding frankly with in earth
science at NASA has been very much you
can his tract concerns about climate and
other global issues so we've gone from a
relatively modest program in a science
program at NASA that was primarily
focused on on outer space to i believe
the largest division in that NASA
program which you know get several order
of magnitudes of increase all because of
concerns about the Anthropocene so we
really owe our existence and prominence
today to that to those concerns and the
fact that there's this planetary view
that is offered here's another planetary
view probably more relevant for the
ampersand for presenting nights at light
you guys have seen this but as opposed
to the Blue Marble some people call this
the black marble new spacecraft up veers
is going to be getting these data
regularly this is from a NOAA generated
image or mosaic from from a DoD
satellite but it really shows you where
people are and their impact on the
planet in terms of energy use and that's
huge you know where we where are we
pulling the energy out of the system and
in most prominent sand there's you know
you can see the planet there dimly in
spots so I mentioned the fact that we we
look at the Earth from space we do it in
any number of different bands of the
electromagnetic spectrum passive optical
active etcetera we look at the oceans we
look at atmosphere we look at land we
look at solid earth we look at the
gravity field any number of things this
is a current suite of just NASA
satellites up there and operating there
are a host of others you know Noah has
their satellites that they operate the
international community has satellites
so point here is just there's a lot of
data out there a lot of information
that's now coming back you know
petabytes of data on a regular basis
about elements of the earth systems
think of it as the environmental data
set but what is that you know that's
great but what does biodiversity
research actually have in conservation
derived from that actually had to gain
from these from these looks and how does
that really relate to folks that are
that are worried about biodiversity loss
can we make the connections well scale
is is obviously the issue here
satellites are good at getting out
pattern not so much process but at least
getting to patterns these are three
images just varying pixel sizes modis on
the right here is sort of 252 one
kilometer data that's free data I'm
going to point out costs because cost
and data access matters here free data
for the last 10 years since its
inception Landsat 30 meter pixels again
sort of an order magnitude jump in much
higher resolution used to cost up until
just a couple of years ago six hundred
dollars a scene 10 years or so before
that it was a couple of thousand bucks
to see so you can see that doing global
science at six hundred dollars a scene
is pretty prohibited now what happened
in the last two two or three years I
think that it's really revolutionized
things is the US Geological Survey which
operates the satellite the Landsat
satellites NASA builds and launch them
launches in terms of over to usgs to
operate made all of those data both the
new data and the archive free and that's
meant you can get this 30 meter
landscape scale data at no cost and you
can start assembling mosaics not Matt's
going to talk about that Matt Hanson
coming up here I'm not going to get into
that but you can just imagine that is
just open the doors kick the doors down
in terms of our ability to work at
landscape scales and do it globe
huge and and of course that wouldn't
have been possible not only date a
policy but frankly you know Moore's law
has played a huge role here 15 maybe
even 10 years ago even if the data were
free we couldn't have done it I mean an
MSS scene which was about half you know
a tkt meter resolution twice as courses
that you could work with one quarter of
those on a computer back when I started
out not that long ago you couldn't even
do a full MSS scene at one time on your
lap on your own you there were no
laptops on your computer your desktop so
revolutionary right now we're at a great
time and then finally is commercial data
is still costing hundreds maybe
thousands or two dollars a scene again
very high spatial resolution such as you
can get down to the canopy's
particularly in a panchromatic context
and identify individual trees so you can
see getting finer finer in terms of
pattern in some cases you can derive
processes directly but mostly mostly you
have to do so indirectly now when you
think of biodiversity data this is what
you tend to think about in terms of
biodiversity observations landscapes
individual organisms from plots in
spreadsheets or genomes or elements or
barcodes elements molecular elements of
genetic fragments oh we're trying to
relate those pixels those raster based
pixel data sets to these other types of
data sets and they're fundamentally
different their pointer or polygons
vectors often trying to compare those to
raster so you've got it you've got a
conversion issue there you also
obviously got scale issues so what can
we do with that well just in terms of
remote sensing of biodiversity you can
sort of simply think of it is to you
know to sort of broad based approaches
to it increasingly because of high
spatial I allow that iconos image and
high spectral hyper spectral resolution
where you take the electromagnetic
spectrum running from in some cases the
UV out through the visible into the
near-infrared and you parse that
spectrum not into individual bands or
channels or colors but you parse that
whole spectrum into 10 nanometer
fragments very small fragments and you
project the entire spectrum so when I
say high spatial resolution high
spectral resolution excuse me that's
what I'm talking about taking the whole
spectrum the whole picture not just
discreet portions of it so increasingly
using high spatial and high spectral
resolution
actually designate tax species down to
the genus or species level with imagery
very powerful very cool not cheap
necessarily to do in terms of the high
spatial resolution but but it's doable
and Google Earth has made it very
popular and has enabled thousands of
people to get their hands dirty playing
with it the other more common approach
least from the NASA perspective with
coarser pixel data of course a
resolution imagery is basically to
indirectly get at biodiversity or
elements of biodiversity through proxies
such as primary productivity climate
habitat I pull these three out because
they're you know something that Robert
MacArthur addressed in Geographic
ecology back way back in the 70s as
being sort of key parameters that one
would need to to get at to get sort of
to get to by geographically relevant
information Heathrow sort of three
productivity climate structure out and
we can do that I'm going to talk about
that but I love this quote from the car
that I've used it before basically his
point that concept a pattern
irregularity is central to science
pattern imply some sort of repetition if
there's repetition that means perhaps
prediction is possible that having
witnessed something once we can
partially predict its future course when
it repeats itself so saying that there
is power and pattern in terms of getting
out through modeling the processes that
underlie those those patterns so here's
just an example of the high spatial this
is from Scott Bergen while life
conservation society who was counting
elk up in Wyoming with this is quick
bird imagery so very high-resolution
data sort of down four meters in in and
he's using shadow here to actually get
numbers of elk he's done it with bison
they've done it with elephant seals and
you can tell by where certain elk or by
against guess he was doing a bison and
elephant seals where the males are and
where the other males are and the
dominance of the sub subordinates based
on their positioning and so you know
shadows are great and so you can
actually use this to count with he was
getting like ninety percent accuracies
this is open on snow of course so you
know this is not normal but people done
with work to an elephants in Africa
ungulate so there are examples where you
can actually do some some interesting
stuff certain types of tree
be clearly now high spectral is even I
think more promising in terms of this is
from Phil Townsend in his group at
Wisconsin where they all think they have
done this back when he was at Maryland
but this he's looking at just two looks
one Shannon doe the other in Western
Maryland out and get County where he's
used a spectrometer an airborne not sad
like this is averaged eight an airborne
spectrometer that parses that spectrum
very finely as i mentioned to get
essentially signals reflected signals
that are discrete to species and so he's
broken down different types of oaks
pines he's got some hemlock in there and
some Hickory where he's been able to
sort of parse it out and brown through
the validate and have again fairly high
accuracies in his ability to distinguish
clumps of species within the within the
within the canopy using high spectral
resolution but the primary approach
really is to use satellite imagery as an
input two models not to directly but to
indirectly use the data to get at
elements of biodiversity and and this
it's really important I think and this
is a theme that will recur through the
talk the importance of place in number
as being very important variables to get
at 444 ecology what was where and how
many of them were there this is
something that's very built into human
nature i think you know you saw what
okay where was it and how many I'm were
there I mean whether you're hunting it
or they're coming to hunt you or
whatever hat those are just those are
hardwired in our psyche and so they sort
of form the basis of a lot of ecology
frankly so if you get those parameters
you can you can get a lot so we need
models both of distribution the where
but we also need to know abundance to
really make to have power and more on
that later and in terms of modeling
we've heard a lot about this and we'll
hear more i'm looking forward to simon's
talk where this is this is very
simplistic and just sort of broken it
down into two broad approaches for for
modeling what i'm calling outside in
which is basically working from the
environment to the organism where you're
basically using more statistical ink
relative approaches think of habitat
suitability modeling or traditional nish
modeling in this way there's certain
advantages to that
if you've got species distribution data
environmental information you can you
can make it run it gives you broad
coverage taxonomically you don't have to
necessarily worry about having a lot of
specific species information there but
you lose a lot in the process in terms
of the understanding of processes
understanding the physiology
understanding of interactions phylogeny
other things that are important so it's
it's limited but it's broadly applicable
it's easy to use and it's been very very
common most studies you see in the
literature are still built on
correlative modeling outside in modeling
approach the other approach again
simplistically thinking speaking here is
inside out starting with the organism
itself in its own physiology its own
behavior perhaps its own phylogeny
perhaps it's is derived from from from
genetics molecular information to model
out to the environment that it can that
it can stand I mean this is basically
getting at the processes the why when
you really understand what the limits
are on that species and frankly while
most climate change work in terms of
biodiversity is use these types of
models you really need to use these
because we honestly don't know what
species are able to tolerate in terms of
temperatures precipitation their
abilities to move so this more
mechanistic physiological approach is
very data intensive it's therefore hard
to do in many cases in terms of its data
requirements but it does get you to the
Y and there's a lot of exciting work
going on colleagues of Simon folks here
in the states about in terms of
integrating these these what I'm again
simplistically calling two approaches to
modeling elements of biodiversity with
environmental data and then there's also
population this is a old actually I
pulled it off the web it's recent but
it's it's an old slide that I've updated
from reseda kakaya at suny where he's
basically is ramas GIS approach bringing
in demographic information and
demographic modeling into conjunction
with landscape more traditional
landscape and environmental modeling to
try to come up with a population
viability analysis for four species
change over time so you need to place
and the number and then this is a nice
paper from Dawson where he's sort of
this is the big enchilada if you will
came out accompanied me said okay in
terms of trying to understand how
climate is likely to impact biodiversity
you know you need all of this really you
need the observations of the organisms
where they are which I'm going to argue
very soon or quite limiting you need
those correlative climate envelope mr.
models but you also need the
physiological data you want to look at
what's happened in the past you want to
bring in history so phylogeny
paleontological data or important
population modeling is also key to note
to know what is likely to happen from a
PHP a context or another population
context and then you want to you know
experimental manipulations well what's
this what's going to happen if we double
co2 what temperature goes up it gets
this this much drier this much wetter so
all of these are really necessary to
sort of understand it from a climate
change perspective how my taxon is
likely to change and so all of these
become environmental or biodiversity
records that we need to really do this
job of understanding in a changing
climate how biodiversity is likely to
change this is a neat paper from a new
swatch tantrum who's in Ralph Tobias
group at University of Maryland and I
throw it up here just to show that it
sort of was a look at the importance of
different types of data at getting at
prevalence in this case of migratory
bird species in the northeastern US this
is from Hubbard Brook experimental
forest in New Hampshire they looked at
nine bird species along the bottom here
black polo our Lord black-throated blue
magnolia water'll yellow-rumped warbler
oven birds a bunch of war was in the
red-eyed Vireo dark-eyed vireo and the
yellow-bellied flycatcher in terms of
their dark-eyed junco excuse me
yellow-bellied flycatcher in terms of
the the prevalence of these birds and
they were trying to characterize using
using a random forest accredited model
is in terms of independent for the
environmental data they're after both
essentially Landsat textural data from
from ndvi from taking two bands of
Landsat income
as well as structural data that they got
from a laser a lidar to actually
different types of lighters I won't go
into that but two types of lidar it's
discreet and waveform and a radar but
those are all airborne datasets with the
exception of the Landsat in sort of
determine and then they took things away
to say okay what what it gives you the
most power to make it short the lidar
proved to have the most power the
structural information when you're
getting down to small relatively small
area like Hubbard Brook this isn't
continental so scale matters here by the
way if you were doing this continental
then maybe the NDVI the landsat would be
a more powerful tool but when you're
getting onto down to the close to the
site level structures macarthur
theorized is quite important and so that
lidar had the most power the landsat
ndvi second and then the radar which is
again gets you the structure but radars
funky the backscatter is affected by
water and it requires a lot more
interpretation whereas the lidar is a
much more direct it's basically a laser
it's blue I'm sorry it's green light or
red light bounce down coming through the
canopy you know hitting everything Bubba
mum come back to the surface and
bouncing back and you're reading that
backscatter so you get essentially a
direct look of what's where the lights
are and where the lights aren't of where
the structure of the foliage is from
that so that structure is really is
really powerful and then this is another
this is sort of again Greg Asner's work
from the Carnegie airborne observatory
in Peru Brazilian Amazon in South
America and this is sort of taking it to
the next step again this is airborne
data he's what he's done is he's
outfitted and this is the basically the
neon model that he's following but he
developed it has been applying it in the
tropics where he's got a lidar again the
laser downward looking bouncing off
agitation going all the way to surface
coming back and then he's got a
spectrometer not just the Landsat
multispectral you know seven eight bands
chopped up the spectrum into these
little chunks but he's got the whole
spectrum going from you know almost from
the UV from the very beginning of the
visible out through the near-infrared
okay his a one continuous spectrum one
big wave and so he's looking at that and
what he's finding is that the
reflectance that you get from the
spectrometer is affected no big surprise
here by the biochemistry of the plant
and that that biochemistry also has a
taxonomic relationship so he's been
assembling very large libraries this is
obviously a very complex area maybe the
most complex area you can think of as
sort of Amazon Andy's right there that
the transition zone and he's been able
to relate reflectances to biochemistry
two taxa and so and then also throwing
in the structural data gives him that
that that 3d that niche component so we
sort of got the whole enchilada in terms
of ecosystem composition from the
spectrum structure from the lidar and
then the functional aspects which are
also spectrally and somewhat
structurally derived ok so the
biogeochemistry so it's a nice
combination and here he's sort of
colored different trees different colors
and you got the structure feel so
there's a depth there and this is an
airplane so you know you fly back and
you five de facto forth back forth back
before you take a lot of data but it's
just it's you can only do so much with a
plane and so the dream is to get these
suckers in space to where you've got a
spectrometer up there orbiting this
would this is a plan for 60 meters pixel
spectrometer from the from the running
from the UV at 380 nanometers out to 25
hundred nanometers and the thermal
multispectral sensor on it called
history which I've been working on a bit
and then an ice at which wich is a light
are built to look at ice but it also has
vegetation components as the earlier one
has demonstrated this is a new
technology hopefully photon counting
will work as well as the old technology
will see there's some skepticism out
there but we'll figure it out but anyway
my point in showing these are just to
say new satellites hopefully can bring
these two approaches together structure
and function composition into a global
ability at fairly fairly high relatively
high spatial resolution to get at some
of these parameters but it you're still
going to have to model most things and
so we also need a capability to assess
arted them I will talk with this point
and that is that you know if I have a
one word title abbr be entered
eration I didn't say that but it's
that's that's true our integral
integration is imperative would be that
sort of the three word title for this
for this talk and by that I mean
integration across scales across
disciplines across communities in this
Crais across modeling type so
interoperability is key this is
something Gary Geller out of Jet
Propulsion lab in Pasadena has put
together something he's been working on
for a couple years because of the model
web and his concept is to try to make
outputs of models act as web services so
that one models output can be the inputs
to another via the web and it's fairly
easy that actually integrate models you
got aggregation of error issues there
obviously but nonetheless at least
you've got model talking to model and so
here's something he does he derived
we're working with you know the folks at
NASA Ames where you've got global
climate data and local climate or
regional climate data feeding a
biogeochemical cycling model which can
feed fire models or land cover models
which in turn can provide inputs to more
the correlative type niche model and get
at species distribution all to answer a
big question like as the climate changes
can rare species X still exists within
my protected area in 20 57 so to try to
get at this so it's really about pulling
models together and developing a
capability for interoperable modeling
this is an actual example of such from
from francisco chavez at monterey bay
aquarium research institute one of our
investigators where frankly the
oceanographers i think are ahead in this
game relatives of terrestrial people in
some ways they've had they have some
ways less data so they've had they've
been more challenged and and they've
been i think more aggressive about this
what's running down here the bottom is
is they just stop is a regional go yeah
a regional pacific basin wide ocean
model a rom and i believe that i think
that's temperature not height i believe
that sea surface temperature that's
running there anyway that physical ocean
model generates 12 and a half kilometer
outputs for the entire base and they
feed from the physical model you
basically feed biogeochemical models
that eh I University of Maine is
developed called cosine which links
biogeochemistry to life through
phytoplankton basis through a TRO
model so you go from biogeochemistry
these outputs here too small and larger
phytoplankton the base of the food chain
in the ocean and then tried and this is
the big trick going from phyto tazo
plankton is the really hard thing to do
the grazers but they've added Enzo
plankton to this model and it's working
well enough this the use here was to try
to come up with a forecasting tool for
chinook salmon in the central California
system you know we know what happens to
them better anyway what happens to them
on the terrestrial part of the life
cycle when they get in the ocean sort of
a black box what's affecting them in the
ocean in terms of the return of those
Simon to to actually spawn this is an
attempt to get at that and they've
issued I think nine-month forecast now
nine months in advance forecast of
weather is going to be a good bad salmon
year coming up based on this this
integrated model and he got francisco's
peruvian so he got started working in
peru world's largest fishery and she
ivetta down there the provements have
incredibly well monitored boats hella
complained so so it was a great day to
set to start with and now he's working
with with something of the u.s. not
going to talk too much about this one
because time is tight but wanting to get
to a paper that to me was sort of a big
deal I don't know how big a deal was for
a lot of folks this is Pereira and
Cooper's paper and tree in 2006 and what
got me so excited about I think a lot of
people so excited particularly the Geo
context I'll talk about a little bit is
it it's it was one of the first papers
to really integrate remote sensing and
and large-scale global and regional
biodiversity accounting systems if you
will or measuring systems into one
common framework so he sort of he has
basically he called here for essentially
two strands if you will an environmental
strand which was fed by remote sensing
and and ground-based information on the
environment and a biodiversity strand
which was fed by global assessments so
what rato and others talking about in
terms of mammal assessment and feeding
us has some sets of birds driven by red
list tools
by the Living Planet Index again these
global indices handful that exist out
there as well as regional efforts like
the breeding bird surveys in the US and
the UK and other efforts to essentially
come up with these parallel lines of
data that would provide a way to monitor
biodiversity from the top down do it
globally which you know at the time I
was like that's what I've wanted to do
but it didn't really know you know
hadn't sort of put it all together and
this paper was really need in doing that
it's it's it's it's a little dated now
but it's still worth checking out and he
even came up with sort of a political
framework with this is the really
hardest part guys down here at the
bottom you know how does this actually
work from a policy standpoint who's
going to pay for this what's what's the
political framework the national
framework in which it exists he pointed
out the groupon earth observations more
on that later as being a group to bring
this out here's a schematic that sort of
shows these lines spatially global
programs and regional programs and then
breaking out between environmental and
biodiversity along the bottom but in
this this paper came out around the time
that geo was getting started so in terms
of the organization of geo bomb the geo
by divert biodiversity observation
network talk about that in a minute this
was this paper was sort of a very
instrumental in r EK has been on the
steering committee of that group so it's
been said it had a sort of
disproportionate impact i'd say on that
group's thinking and now we saw a lot of
slides on from from walter yesterday on
this but one way to look at the map of
life there are a lot of ways to approach
it but one way to approach it is in the
sort of this context of global
frameworks for understanding
biodiversity and how it's changing
bearing them together these different
types of data sets and integrating
models in some ways this is a this is a
more sophisticated version of what
Enrique and David we're doing back in
2006 both in terms of the the data sets
the observations sweet it involved as
well as the ability to integrate those
data through models and essentially
bioinformatics tools and the web citizen
science tools into into a holistic
approach which I you know when I again
when I read
Walter and Jana and Rob's paper I you
know again is so that wow this is it's
coming together I can sort of see it
it's a nice nice road map here they're
their pieces that are discrete and
identifiable and we can go from there
this folk this of course focuses on
species distribution doesn't get to that
abundance issue we talked about earlier
but it's it's a start and that's you
know we can bring those data in I was
really Steve's talk it from about eBird
yesterday and a couple others where
people are actually getting abundance
data those data or gold you know how
many that LPI and other great data set
in terms of getting it number that's
gold and we can help in you can bring
that into the system I think quite quite
readily so maybe this is a enrique and
pereira 2.0 or something and then this
slide what I'm trying to do is just say
why would we even assuming we can do all
this would we go global from a couple of
perspectives both the users of the press
are the producer of the data and the the
user of the data just list these out
quickly that you can you can read them I
don't want necessarily go through them
due to time but you can get a sense here
of what we get the bang for the buck
that we get by going global i think it's
it's a it's a fairly compelling case
both from the the producer side the data
provider side as well as the consumer
side the data user solve this slide
yesterday and the take-home message that
that I take from this is that you know
there's some quite robust data sets on
the environmental side many
satellite-based not all some model base
but that biodiversity data in general
limiting but in particular what's
important or time series of biodiversity
data we need those time series we need
to get observations up we need time
series without the time series doing
predictive science is going to be very
very difficult the good news in terms of
biodiversity observations of there as
you all we'll know new sources of data
out there in terms of getting it in situ
data at the organismal level camera
traps lights important but so is sound
lots of things happen at night
we can't see it with light and so
capturing things sonically or is
extremely important and the tools there
are even perhaps more powerful in the
fact that you know you can do a Shazam
with your cell phone in a you know in a
store you hear a song and it's like
what's that song I don't know well you
know hold your phone up and it can
identify the song and sell it to you is
extremely useful in terms do you think
birdcalls insects a number of things so
we're getting more sophisticated I know
is it jumped from you know Skinner to
the Tudor safa law but it's it's still
it's doable and so in terms of just what
do we need to do bringing these pieces
together there are a number of existing
tools out there and datasets that we've
heard a lot about the key is to organize
them this would be the expert base piece
both in terms I'm talking I believe it
from genetics data to organismal data
the assessments bird survey data as well
as networks down here want to really
highlight plot networks the SI geo group
the team activity and a number of others
that are generating plot data it's it's
key to integrate these these these plot
efforts these networks they don't all
have to be measuring the same thing in
the same way but at some level they need
to be integrated so that we can call
their products off the top and pump up
the number of biodiversity observations
particularly biodiversity time series
that are being developed so the
challenge there is to sort of bring a
framework in which all of these players
can start working together to make their
observations available and then going
beyond the experts to the volunteers the
interested public who may well be expert
in their own right to bring in citizen
science as a way to really inflate those
observations heard a lot about it
yesterday don't need to spend much time
on that I will point to another enrique
pereira piece in frontiers just a couple
years back where he estimated that for
about 50k a year we could have groups of
experts and volunteers focusing on a
selected taxa terrestrial vertebrates
butterflies and key plants in regions of
developing regions of the world and it
would be you know for that we could
generate the data we would need to
outfit a biodiversity monitoring system
and so do we have the pieces here's
here's the list of what I think are
necessary the big the big five if you
will rated in order of whether we have
it or not how easy it is David whether
whether successful and starting from one
with what we've gotten to what we don't
have so those are those the big ones
satellite data time series observations
of biodiversity interoperable frameworks
of models to develop a predictive
science bioinformatics cyber
infrastructure and then the most
difficult challenging is sort of the
institutional framework to make it all
to make them play together I think geo
group on earth observations is such a
framework and geo bond in particular as
an element of it is key I think Walter
mate and not Walter but Simon might
mention that in his talk no I thought
you were initially so I didn't go into
much detail but yeah we each thought the
other was doing it but it is it is an
international framework based at the
governmental level and with
international organizations that is
about about coordinating observations
one of its elements is biodiversity and
one of its key products is geo bond so
there is I think a political framework
to fit this within looking at climate
this is a this is a possible model for
us to follow you've got two different
elements here research assessment policy
and observations for the climate
community which has been quite
successful in terms of getting
observations to assessments at least to
an international policy framework how
successful they've been in implementing
the policy we can argue but nonetheless
there is a framework out there that they
feed and so this is this is something
that we could emulate they've come up
with essential climate variables that
they think are necessary to measure for
time for long-term here's a biodiversity
look at that globally the pieces again
that with the formation of it that's
just last year I think are all there we
giovan is trying to set up something
called essential biodiversity variables
I think these will be key long-term
records and Alexander a CBS essential
climate burials that we can use
to feed our our modeling systems and
then we're also fortunate almost done
sorry Walter and going along here within
the u.s. there's a comfortable framework
that since the PCAST report the
President's Council of Advisors on
science of technology came out with this
report about a year and a half ago that
we've now so we're setting up sort of a
parallel framework within the u.s. of
observations assessments and policy that
could mirror what's happening at global
scale so again timing is on our side and
I think this is my next to last chart
just some of the issues and challenges
I'm going to hit these interns because i
think they are so important open data
policies are critical if the data aren't
available preferably at no cost this
doesn't work we have to actually link
people from the communities it's not
enough for the biodiversity community to
try to do this so certainly for the
remote sensing community to try to do
this on it's only they really need to be
jointly linked Cal valor is critical we
got we've got to validate the data we
have organized a site networks then
choose taxa that that to start it's
going to be hard to choose the tax but
it's I think is going to be defective
taking advantage of the tax that we're
already being observed enable model
interoperability move out on all these
fronts at once in terms of observations
modeling assessments you need a sampling
scheme to put these all in government
should be involved and geo may offer I
think it does offer the way forward here
use the web and engage citizens and then
finally my dad's mantra you know
mistakes are okay don't be afraid to
screw up so go ahead and start and this
is the final slide he just shows the the
workshop that Walter put together for us
which I think he was quite quite
brilliant actually if you look at the
the folks that are here not so much the
people but also what they represent you
really got the components of the
framework the pieces are there in terms
of biodiversity observation networks
citizen science groups some remote
sensing elements we're going to hear
more about soon modeling efforts we're
also going to hear a lot more about that
soon that the data and integration piece
is challenging bringing the marine
realms putting it in the broader context
climate change so it's a it's a great
dis impose iam thanks for organizing it
and sorry I was so verbal verbose